[Musique]
en ce début d'hiver le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
la commune de bonnel et l'association
bullion bonnel nature ont invité les
habitants à venir participer à un
chantier nature sur la réserve naturelle
régionale des étangs de bonnel au
programme de ce dimanche matin
l'entretien et la restauration d'une
roselière avec création de mares et même
d'abri pour animaux sauvages la
roselière c'est un milieu ouvert donc
qui a besoin de lumière besoin dos à
l'eau elle est là mais par contre besoin
de lumière donc on a on a travaillé à du
petit bûcheronnage pour couper quelques
petits arbres et quelques un peu plus
grand et puis ensuite rangé tout ça bien
proprement venir à remettre la roselière
en lumière pour qu elle ce qu'elle
puisse se développer
s'agrandir un petit peu et puis et puis
éviter que ça se trouve que le milieu se
referme avec ses 2 étend ses sources
s'arrose lierse et boisement ces
prairies et la rivière gloriette la
réserve naturelle présente une
remarquable variété de paysages et de
milieux naturels qu'il faut préserver
alors si vous souhaitez planter des
haies et des arbres fruitiers ou même
revaloriser des fontaines n'hésitez pas
à venir donner un peu de votre temps et
de votre énergie pour apporter votre
contribution à la préservation de la
biodiversité et des paysages du parc